>>I would prefer you to not take the
calculator outta the room, thinking,
"I need to use my calculator,"
and then leave it on the stairs
and then I cry, when I'm like,
"Where's the calculator?"
>>Ben is my math teacher.
He immediately made the
impression on me that he was funny
and that he was eager to teach kids
and that he really liked his job.
He wants you to really reach
and get better at math.
>>My name is Benjamin Mook.
I'm a math teacher at
School of the Future.
I teach the seventh and
eighth grade math cycle.
If you think about to de-- What I'd
say is an authentic assessment would
be something that a teacher
could design to hit the skills
and the needs of their population.
Some of these things that I'm
assessing are not necessarily
that kids can get to a right answer,
but that kids, once they have
that right answer, can understand,
"I got to this right answer
because I followed steps."
I'll just pose questions and try to
figure out what common mistakes are.
And when I can get a whole mess
of like ten or fifteen mistakes,
that it doesn't even
matter who made them.
Like I could have a kid that's an
A student that has like an error
in logic on how to do a certain type
of problem, and then I can use that
and pose that as a
question to students later.
So I'll take a mistake that they'll
make and then, one or two days later,
I'll throw it back into the class.
>>So what I want you to do is
this: based on the information
on this sheet-- there you go.
>>One of my more favorite
types of assessment is
to actually give them incorrect
work or incorrect answers
and have them break down the
error in thought process, of,
"How could a student who's not
as well educated as you-- ?"
or start out like that.
Like, "You would never make
this mistake, but somebody did,
and how would this mistake happen
and how could you, as a classmate
or a tutor, remediate this mistake?"
>>Today they were applying the slope
formula to a set of stairs and seeing
if they were in compliance with
New York City building codes.
Okay, this is the math.
This is how the math connects to
the real life, and that was my goal.
>>I really like that we get
to use our hands in class
and that we really get to experience
this in a real life situation,
and that it's not just,
"Here's the formula."
It's like, "Here's why the formula
works and, you know, here's something
to prove it, or here's how
you could think about it."
>>Things that I'm doing
now I've designed
so that during a class period, the
student is working and I am able
to walk around and kind of coach
them through what they are doing.
And so I can look and anticipate
the problems they're having,
so in the classroom, I'm
spending a lot less energy.
Like I end the school
day now not tired.
>>When we talk about
authentic assessment,
obviously things can
only be as authentic
within the four walls of a school.
So we want the tasks that they do to
challenge them to synthesize things
and to approach problems in
the way that a scientist does
or historian does or a
reader does or a writer does,
and to make those tasks and those
challenges as authentic as possible.
>>And five minutes from now,
we get back to each other.
>>I think not only Ben but the
rest of the teachers at SOF
and at the school, they really
do want you to think about it
and their main goal is not to
get you to the right answer,
but to show how you got there, and
show that you really put effort
into what you were thinking.
>>The thing that I
find most important is
that I'm not assessing my kids
to be able to give them an A, B,
C or D. Like that's
not gonna help my kids.
I would say that the best use
of assessment is to figure
out where they're at and how I can
get them to where I want them to be.